sandro gozi of the italian undersecretary
for european affairs and with you i would like to
talk about the main topics of this
presidency but they can't start with the
topic of the day i would say in gaza the gates of
europe there is a war now and
europe is conspicuous by its absence  as
always I must say the Italian presidency is also
conspicuous by its absence we
have not heard from premier renzi because
no concrete initiative because
we have said the thing to do and we are
working on an immediate ceasefire
the authorities must first
stop because this escalation is very
worrying for everyone so we
agree as italy with the
european union with the united states to
first of all invite everyone to stand by the
fire this is the immediate urgency
while in the meantime there are the christ
is not a special envoy who
stops gas  it is a
determined influential political reaction we are carrying it
out and we hope that the
Israeli government also listens to our  ro
invite
well then what ever strong in our
semester the economy and the recovery of
growth there is much talk of a
more flexible interpretation of the fact
however in these days we hear
how strong attention is in europe the
current commissioner pro tempore
katainen said that the  path of the creative
flexibility is dangerous we need to
make reforms and that's it how do you judge
this position of firmness that comes
from northern europe i
judge that the only danger that really exists in
europe is to insist on one
single cure austerity which has led to this
recession which has  led to these
very high levels of unemployment I
was very surprised at the divergence
of views that emerged between the
pro tempore commissioner katainen the
new president of the
European commission junker who used words he
made commitments very different from those
of the commissioner because young in the light
of the  agenda will be worth a while and in the light
of the decision of the gove heads of state
rno who is responsible for deciding the
basic political guidelines of the
European Union has clearly
indicated his willingness to make the best use of
the flexibility existing in the
rules catania seems to want to go
back to the present
commission as pro tempore commissioner
who also aspires to be a member  of the new
commission junker and quite
original in its attitude and it is
surprising that a commissioner
goes against the will of the European things in this way
but concrete measures are needed
above all rapid responses you
propose a plan for the
industrial relaunch that objective we are
satisfied because various results of
our  month have already been achieved in
terms of political orientation for
example the commitment that the commitment
that Junker has made to develop a
public and private investment plan
with additional resources of 300 billion
which was a proposal Junker said the figure
then he will tell us where he finds the 300
billion but it was a p  clear proposal
firm high priority of the
Italian presidency just as it is a high priority
of the present Italian company to
relaunch industrial policy
from this point of view we want to
take up the idea of ​​the
compact industry i.e. we want that in Europe
when we talk about the economy not  we are
only talking about finance but above all we are talking
about real production which also means the
creation of new businesses
jobs this is not done only with a
European industrial policy
here is the proposal from industrial compaq
on which we will work and we will
present proposals at the end  of our
month there is another theme that has always
been the heart of italy
priority and migration in the last
european council it seems that for the idea
it was no longer a priority because there was
the great negotiation on flexibility
the impression  that we wanted and that
yes there was this shift but during
the semester what concretely can be
done to act on the em  emergencies therefore
a joint action on the mediterranean sea frontex
i began to launch the poles for
a possible revision of the policy
and immigration but we did not debate
much because we were very satisfied
with the conclusions of the european council
and the conclusions considering that they do not
pay much italian absolutely
disagree with you the conclusions I
consider first of all in commit
all to use the trinci to
truly apply the principles of responsibility
and burden sharing in the
management of the common border the
Mediterranean commit to strengthen
frontex commit to develop a
common asylum policy commitment to
develop those pertariati for
mobility, i.e. the agreements between the
European Union and transit countries of origin
which are one of the points of the fundamental points
even point to something that is a
great Italian priority for the semester and
which we have politically achieved, i.e.
by studying  work and to study the creation
of a police force of the
common borders are obviously not done in six
months in a year but it could be a matter of
legislature
now we need to implement it and for us the
first point is to increase operations the
frontex resource for  support and
progressively replace the
operations that we carry out with mare
nostrum sandro gozi thanks thanks to you